Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, wollen wir nicht Grönland übernehmen? Es werden dann nochmal so 55.000
Hörerinnen. Ich glaube, wir brauchen das.
Wir brauchen nur zwei Hundeschlitten.
WDR mediagroup GmbH im Auftrag des WDR.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 542.
Ihr merkt schon, eine Sendung.
In der es wirkliche Antworten geben wird. Endlich mal. Nicht immer nur Fragen, wie sonst.
Und das Ganze am 14. Januar 2026.
Ja.
Das ist der Tag der Antworten.
Heute wird es endlich alles beantwortet. Jetzt wird alles Sinn machen.
Ja, was bis heute auch nicht gefragt wurde, geht dann auch leer aus,
weil danach ist ja dann erstmal vorbei.
Ja, dann ist ja alles beantwortet.
Genau, das war's dann.
So hat's die 42 an sich.
So sieht's aus. Ja, ja, Grönland, ach man, ey.
Ich weiß nicht, wie geht's, also ich weiß ja, dass eine Menge Leute völlig verstört
sind davon, dass diese Welt so verstört ist.
Eine Menge Leute entdecken gerade, wie sehr sie an Grönland hängen.
Ja, jahrelang vernachlässigt.
Wie geht es Ihnen, wenn Sie an Grönland gehen? Warst du mal an Grönland? Nee, ich auch nicht.
Vielleicht haben wir die letzte Chance verpasst.
Ich brauche das aber für meine Sicherheit.
Unbedingt. Ach ja, naja, okay.
Also die verrückte Welt ist weiterhin verrückt. Wir versuchen hier noch alle
Sinne beisammen zu behalten.
Und wie könnte man das schöner machen als mit Feedback?
Hatten wir nämlich, und das meiste dreht sich wenig überraschend,
um den Digital Independence Day, den du ja mit ausgerufen hast.
Und da gab es dann ein paar Anmerkungen, unter anderem von Bianca.
Sie schreibt, die Idee mit dem Digital Independence Day finde ich super.
Seit Jahren warte ich aber vergeblich darauf, dass der Signal Messenger barrierefrei
wird und das helle Design wirklich einheitlich hell einstellbar ist.
Alle Nachrichten als dunkler Text auf hellem Hintergrund.
Leider ist mir bisher noch nicht gelungen, den Signal-Entwicklern verständlich
zu machen, dass hier leider die Barrierefreiheit nicht gewährleistet wird.
Die Rückmeldungen waren bisher nur, dass keine Bugs dahingehend feststellbar seien.
Sie fragt, welche Möglichkeiten habe ich als Einzelperson oder hat die Community
solche Veränderungen anzustoßen?
Ich muss, also es kommt jetzt glaube ich auf die Plattform an.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich mich mit den ganzen Visual und also grundsätzlich mit
Accessibility nicht extrem gut auskenne, aber mit den Anforderungen von Visual
Accessibility nochmal besonders wenig,
aber zumindest auf iOS ist meine Interpretation, dass das eine systemweite Einstellung ist.
Bei mir ist das auch so.
Und meine Frage wäre jetzt, ob die systemweite Einstellungen...
Von Signal ignoriert wird oder ob du ein Betriebssystem benutzt, wo das anders ist.
Bei Android weiß ich nämlich nicht so genau, wie das da ist,
aber diese ganzen Einstellungen,
wo man Kontrasterhöhungen, Farben raus, einzelne Farben raus,
das ist ja, was ich übrigens sehr sinnvoll und gut finde, ein systemweites Setting,
dem sich dann die Applikationen beugen müssen oder es wird ihn überzwungen und
dann könnte es natürlich sein, dass ein paar Farben falsch gedingst werden, aber glaube ich nicht.
Dass es dir gezwungen wird.
Das ist schon etwas.
Was du übernehmen musst. Also auf dem iPhone geht das.
Kann ich jetzt leider nicht so.
Die eigentlich, warum ich das jetzt auch aufgenommen habe, ist natürlich,
dass du oft mit so Open-Source-Lösungen gerade im Bereich Barrierefreiheit unter
Umständen nicht ganz so den Standard vorfindest, wie das bei anderen Apps der Fall ist.
Da weiß ich gar nicht, da würde ich mir gerne den Datenbestand sehen,
weil also grundsätzlich wäre es natürlich so, du könntest versuchen einen Patch
zu schreiben, der das macht und dann müsste man mal gucken,
mit welcher Begründung dieser Patch abgelehnt wird. Ja.
Ja, leider kann ich da jetzt, also genau, also üblicherweise würde ich sagen, ja,
da wo der Code gepflegt wird, kann man mit den Leuten in Verbindung treten,
das entnehme ich ja dem Kommentar, dass du das aber auch schon getan hast und da wurde er abgelehnt,
da würde mich dann jetzt die Begründung interessieren.
Man muss leider sagen, ja, zu wenig Ahnung, was der spezifische Accessibility-Aspekt ist.
Das sind auf jeden Fall so Aspekte, die man berücksichtigen muss,
wenn man Leuten Alternativen vorschlägt.
Weil für manche Leute sind halt die Alternativen dann unter Umständen auch aus
solchen Gründen keine Alternativen.
Wojtek schreibt uns, grundsätzlich halte ich den Digital Independence Day für
eine gute und wichtige Initiative.
Aber.
Das geht noch weiter. Dass der CCC hier unterstützen wirkt, ist ausdrücklich
positiv hervorzuheben.
Kritisch sehe ich jedoch, dass Tim und Linus, wir, ihre eigene Lebensrealität
stark verallgemeinern.
Nach dem Prinzip, wenn ich das schaffe, dann schafft ihr das auch.
Gerade beim Thema WhatsApp ist diese Perspektive aus meiner Sicht zu kurz gedacht.
Eltern mit Kindern, die in Sport, Musik oder anderen Vereinen aktiv sind,
sind auf Gruppenkommunikation angewiesen.
Informationen zu Terminen, Orten und kurzfristigen Änderungen werden nahezu
ausschließlich über bestehende WhatsApp-Gruppen verbreitet.
Solche Gruppen, in denen sich viele Eltern kaum kennen, geschlossen zu einem
anderen Messenger zu bewegen, ist in der Praxis kaum umsetzbar.
Diese Lebensrealität betrifft viele Familien, auch wenn das in der Sendung nur
wenig berücksichtigt wurde.
Ich habe glaube ich gesagt, dass das der Hauptgrund ist, von dieser Plattform
wegzumigrieren, aber wir sammeln mal, oder?
Oder soll ich da jetzt schon was zu sagen?
Ja, ein weiterer Kommentar von Mero geht in die gleiche Richtung.
Ich fasse das mal ein bisschen zusammen. Hier geht es halt um die Erfahrung
sozusagen auch weltweit und teilweise gibt es halt auch Länder,
in dem Fall Tobago, wo das halt sogar mandatory ist.
Also dass man irgendwie die ganze Immigration-Kommunikation über WhatsApp abschließen
muss und über E-Mail und Telefon und so weiter, da überhaupt gar keine funktionierenden
Alternativen existieren.
Also oft haben sich in manchen Ländern diese Messenger auch schon so verselbstständigt,
dass sie fast schon offizielle Kommunikationen geworden sind.
Okay, nehme ich als Punkt an.
In manchen Ländern auch Telegram zum Beispiel auf einem ähnlichen Level.
Ja, okay, weil du da jetzt so drauf rum hattest, das heißt noch lange nicht,
dass du jede Kommunikation darüber machen musst.
Also wenn deine Kindergarten-WhatsApp-Gruppe der eine Grund ist,
dass du dir die App nicht deinstallieren kannst, dann ist es aber noch lange
kein Grund, dass du nicht eine andere installieren und auch nutzen kannst und
deren Nutzung bevorzugen kannst.
Und wenn ich bei Tobago einreise und ausreise und das ohne WhatsApp nicht tun
kann, heißt das nicht, dass ich meine Signal-Kindergartengruppe,
ich habe nämlich mehrere Kindergartengruppen auf Signal,
ausgerechnet jetzt alle nach WhatsApp umziehen muss, nur weil ich nach Tobago einreise.
Das wäre meine erste Entgegnung dazu.
Ja, ich meine, man kann ja generell festhalten, also uns sind natürlich diese
Zwänge der normalen Welt durchaus bewusst,
darum ging es in dem Sinne ja auch gar nicht und gerade bei Messengern und allem,
was halt diesem Netzwerkeffekt unterliegt, ist es halt nun mal so,
wenn andere Leute einen mehr oder weniger dazu zwingen, das zu benutzen,
ist es mit den Alternativen halt dünner.
Ja, okay, da war das jetzt doch Anfang schon mal zu behandeln.
Okay, dann hier meine Entgegnung. Wir hatten ja glaube ich auch den Text von
Marc-Uwe, den er vorgelesen hatte, beim Kongress hinten dran gehängt,
wo er ja vor allem auch betont sei,
mehrere Schritte, kleine, den
einen kleinen Schritt, für den ihr bisher nicht die Zeit genommen hast.
Und ich glaube, dass ich auch, ich hoffe, ich habe so viel über diese Sachen
geredet, ich hoffe, ich habe es auch in der Sendung getan.
Es geht ja einfach mal so darum, vielleicht den kleinen Schritt zu machen,
die Möglichkeiten zu erhalten, zu nutzen.
Aufzuzeigen und ob man jetzt am Ende sein WhatsApp löscht,
oder einfach mal nur die Nutzung stark reduziert oder so Dinge macht,
ich glaube, auch das habe ich in der letzten Sendung gesagt,
dann antwortest du auf WhatsApp halt immer erst abends und hast die Notifications
aus und grudget die Leute dorthin, dir auf der Plattform zu schreiben, wo du es bevorzugst.
Ich glaube, das war auch einer der Kommentare, zu sagen, antworte halt einfach auf Signal.
Kommt eine Frage auf WhatsApp, antwortest auf Signal.
Schon ist dieser Thread, diese Kommunikation dahin gegangen. Also ich verstehe,
Ähm, dass man vor diesem, ich muss vollständig darauf verzichten,
dass das natürlich auch immer nach einem schweren, großen, starken Schritt klingt.
Ähm, und das heißt aber nicht, dass nur weil man sagt, den traue ich mich nicht
und die Kindergartengruppe ist jetzt gerade auf WhatsApp, heißt ja nicht,
dass ich die Kommunikation mit meiner Partnerin oder meinem Partner,
meinem Kind in dem Kindergarten, die haben ja alle so eine Smartwatch,
wo die auch kommunizieren müssen dann mit ihren Eltern, damit die mal wissen, wo die sind und so,
dass man die Kommunikation auch auf WhatsApp abbildet oder nur weil ich jetzt
in Tobago Urlaub gefahren bin alles jetzt auf WhatsApp machen muss.
Das wäre so der vorsichtige Punkt oder die vorsichtige Entgegnung dazu wenn
man es nicht ganz schafft, heißt es ja nicht, dass man sich trotzdem mal einen
Abnabelungsprozess einleitet,
Das ist ein bisschen wie beim Trinken.
Vielleicht kann man nicht ganz auf Alkohol verzichten. Das heißt aber nicht,
dass man sich zu Tode trinken muss.
Dazwischen gibt es ja so ein Spektrum. Es gibt ja so mehrere Ebenen von Alkoholikern.
Man tastet sich da ja langsam ran, bis man dann so full in ist und dann auf
Wasser verzichtet. Das ist halt eine...
Ja, also ich finde vor allem, man muss es nicht unbedingt alles zu religiös angehen.
Was? Nein, doch!
Es geht um einen praktischen Ansatz, der davon getragen ist,
Alternativen überhaupt auch erstmal zu kommunizieren und sozusagen überhaupt
den Raum mal mit der Information zu füllen, dass es diese auch gibt.
Und dass es auf Nachfrage auch...
Durchaus Argumente dafür gibt.
Jetzt meinen natürlich viele so, ja, okay, was ist denn so das,
wo sind denn so die Vorteile?
Und wenn man sagt, Vorteile sind nur technischer Natur,
Verschlüsselung und so, also ich bezeichne das jetzt mal als einen technischen
Vorteil, weil viele Leute das nur als etwas Technisches wahrnehmen,
weil sie dieses Bedrohungsszenario so gar nicht sehen,
Allein schon, weil Kommunikations...
Also Bedrohungsszenario WhatsApp-Gruppe, ne? Wer das nicht wahrnimmt.
Du weißt, was ich sagen will. Also viele Leute machen sich darüber gar keine
Gedanken und deswegen ist so was, aber es ist besser verschlüsselt,
ist für viele Leute halt nicht unbedingt greifbar.
Und natürlich ist es dann gut, wenn man auf...
Andere Vorteile verweisen kann und da sind sie halt auch alle sehr unterschiedlich
und was man als Vorteil empfindet, das liegt dann sehr in der persönlichen Betrachtung.
Schau mal, die Chaos-Bild hat ja dann auch sofort getitelt,
weil es ja auch im CCC mehrere Menschen gibt, die dann doch als Daily Driver
ein Mac haben und dann gesagt wurde, so mit dem Digital Independence Day beginnt
jetzt Linux on the Desktop und nächstes Jahr sitzen sie da alle mit ihren Linux-Geräten.
Fand ich auch mal, also fand ich es auf jeden Fall erstmal super witzig,
vor allem, weil ich ja auch genauso viel Linux nutze, nur eben als Hauptarbeitsgerät diesen Mac habe.
Gleichzeitig, ja, ich benutze Linux, ich benutze mehr Linux,
ich habe mich auch im Nachgang des Digital Independence Day noch mehr mit einigen
Softwarepaketen beschäftigt und so.
Da hatten wir gerade drüber gesprochen, muss ich jetzt nicht auch noch mit eingehen,
was ich da gerade bastle.
Diesen Schritt überhaupt zu gehen, ist doch schon mal entscheidend.
Und deswegen finde ich auch so ein bisschen diese, und ich glaube,
das ist die eigentlich darunterliegende Kritik, zu sagen, ja,
hier ist ein Wechselrezept und heute gehst du zum Dit und dann wird dein WhatsApp gelöscht.
Ich glaube, das ist eine,
So funktioniert die Realität nicht.
Auch zum Beispiel, wenn du Leute anleitest, das ist eine Diskussion,
die habe ich hier mit dem Ralf Stockmann, den kennen ja viele Hörerinnen sicherlich auch, geführt.
Umzug von einem E-Mail-Provider. Das ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr umfängliche Angelegenheit.
Und ich glaube, das Letzte, wozu ich jemandem raten würde, wäre,
wenn man jetzt von Gmail umzieht, am Ende bei Google hinzutippen,
schließ mal den Account.
Weil das hat mitunter vielleicht eine Reihe an Konsequenzen,
die man nicht berücksichtigt hat.
Zum Beispiel, dass das die Recovery-E-Mail-Adresse ist für 30 andere Accounts,
die man noch im Internet hat.
Das heißt, man muss die natürlich auch zumindest weiter unterhalten und sicherstellen,
dass man unter dieser Adresse noch empfangen kann.
Und dann kann man sich überlegen, wie man das macht. Macht man ein Forward?
Lässt man das Ding parallel laufen? Das sind ja alles Dinge,
die man individuell löst.
Und das ist genau der Grund, warum wir in den vielen, vielen CCC-Lokalgruppen
und inzwischen habe ich geguckt, da sind weit über 100 Events jetzt auf diesem Kalender,
sagen, pass auf, wir helfen mal dabei, weil eine App löschen kann jede Ehre.
Aber so praktisch damit umzugehen. Ich glaube, ich hatte es auch in der letzten
Sendung erzählt, dass das natürlich dann die Fragen sind, die Leute stellen.
Mir wird immer noch auf WhatsApp geschrieben und dann redest du darüber,
ja okay, dann antworte halt auf Signal.
Oder wenn ich, und das habe ich schon mehrmals im Leben gemacht,
mit E-Mail-Accounts umgezogen bin, natürlich habe ich von dem alten auf den
neuen einen Forward gehabt und hatte dann genau diesen gleichen Effekt,
dass mir jemand unter der alten Adresse schreibt und ich unter der neuen antworte.
Und genau da kommt ja so dieser Aspekt, dass man eben sagt so,
ja, ja, du stellst dir diesen Schritt jetzt so irre vor, deswegen.
Leiten wir da mal drauf hin. Keiner muss jetzt morgen sein WhatsApp löschen,
außer du, Tim. Also wirklich reicht jetzt.
Aber dein Tobago-Urlaub ist jetzt lange noch her.
Und genau darin zeigt sich doch, warum das so ein Thema ist.
Und warum man sich damit eben auf unterschiedlichsten Ebenen befasst.
Aber ich vermute, du hast noch sehr viel mehr Kommentare, die du vorlesen möchtest.
Nö, ich glaube, also ich würde sagen, im Wesentlichen ist dadurch schon ganz
gut wiedergegeben, was so die primären Bedenken waren.
Und das ist ja auch absolut richtig.
Ein kompletter Wechsel ist jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres möglich.
Die Realität da draußen und die wichtigen Sozialkontakte spielen sich da halt ab.
Wo ist das?
In irgendwelchen Messengers. Es gibt Leute, die sind nur in der Telegram-Welt.
Es gibt Leute, die sind nur über WhatsApp für mich zu erreichen.
Das sind glücklicherweise in meiner Welt sehr wenige. Ein paar.
Auf die habe ich dann irgendwann verzichtet.
Ja, aber das ist nicht mein primäres Kriterium, welchen Messenger die Leute
verwenden, auch wenn sie eine deutlich geringere Chance haben, zu mir durchzudringen.
Und das ist doch, das sind doch genau diese, das sind doch genau diese Aspekte.
Ja, aber wie viele Partys ich schon verpasst habe, jetzt bin ich ganz allein
und einsam. Nur deswegen.
Aber ich hab halt Du meinst, das hat einen anderen Punkt. Da reden wir jetzt nicht drüber.
Also, fassen wir zusammen.
Selbst wenn das Löschen eines WhatsApp-Kontos oder das Löschen eines Twitter-Accounts
oder was weiß ich, wenn man hier mit Tim Jutu abhängig ist oder so.
Selbst wenn das nicht in Frage kommt, heißt das ja nicht, dass man nicht trotzdem Alternativen nutzt.
Und dass man sich vielleicht in der, dass man diese Alternativen priorisiert
und sie sich einfach mal langsam, aber sicher zum Default macht.
Das denke ich ist das Entscheidende hier und ich hatte eigentlich auch gehofft,
dass das ausreichend gut erstens in dem Text von Marc-Uwe rüberkommt und auch in unserem Gespräch.
Ich würde jetzt mal über die Kommentare hinaus erweitern, es gibt interessanterweise,
aber das passiert jedem, der irgendwie mal sich anschickt, vielleicht einfach mal was zu machen,
dann gibt es so eine ganze Reihe und ich finde das, es gibt dann immer so einen
Aufschrei von Leuten, das ist eigentlich auch völlig egal, wer etwas macht,
ja, völlig egal, die dann so,
ich hab das mal so, Ich glaube, das
sind extreme Überinterpretationen von überinterpretierenden Extremisten.
Und zwar diese überinterpretierenden Extremisten und innen, die teilen sich
im Prinzip so in den Prototyp Puritaner,
Prototyp Fatalisten und Fundamentalisten.
Die sagen aber alle das gleiche, das ist falsch, das sollst du nicht tun.
Und sagen damit implizit natürlich auch, der Zustand wie er jetzt ist.
Kann, darf, soll, wird sich nicht ändern. Das ist der zu bevorzugende Zustand.
Und die Puritaner, das ist so, in die Kategorie würde ich diese Leute einteilen, die so sagen, ja,
aber dieser Messenger, der hostet auf AWS und deswegen ist der jetzt auch Gift
und deswegen darf man nicht zu dem umziehen.
Wenn der nicht in der und der Kubernetes-Cloud auf meinem alten 486 hochgezogen werden kann,
dann ist er nicht wirklich frei oder nicht digital souverän oder die haben keine
reproducible Builds, wie kannst du so etwas empfehlen?
Das sind alles so Gedanken, die führen einen nirgendwo hin, weil man dann nämlich
den ersten Schritt nicht macht.
Da denke ich immer an, das ist wirklich ein Zitat, das sehr häufig in meinem
Kopf wiederkommt. Barack Obama,
better is good. Er sagte, wenn etwas besser ist, dann ist es schon mal gut.
Das heißt, es ist fertig, es ist perfekt, aber ein Schritt zu etwas Besserem ist ein guter Schritt.
Und nur weil es nicht der Schritt zu etwas Perfektem ist, heißt es nicht,
dass wir den Schritt nicht tun. Das ist so puritaner.
Hopfen, Malz, Hefe und Wasser. Mehr darf da nicht drin sein im Messer.
Genau, absolutes Reinheitsgebot. Da dürfen nur Bits aus Bodenhaltung.
Bodenhaltung, Entschuldigung, also das muss schon irgendwie Freiland sein.
Ja, ja, stimmt. Freilandhaltung.
Sonst sind die ja immer noch eingesperrt.
Also, dieser Zielanspruch ist richtig, aber auf dem Weg dahin.
Muss man halt noch so das eine oder andere Legebatterie-Ei essen oder so, ne?
Also nur weil man nicht sofort am Ziel ist, heißt das nicht,
dass man nicht den Schritt in die richtige Richtung geht. Dann gibt es die Vaterlisten.
Das ist realitätsfremd. Oder dann Kindergartengruppe oder so.
Und außerdem individuelle Antworten auf systemische Probleme lehne ich grundsätzlich ab, ja?
Wir müssen das gesamte System ändern. es gibt kein richtiges Leben im Falschen.
Wir müssen ja einfach grundsätzlich alles ablehnen und in der Diskussion darüber,
was wir alles ablehnen, bleiben wir einfach da, wo wir sind.
Ja, das würde ich sagen, das sind so die Fatalisten.
Und dann gibt es die Fundamentalisten, die das dann direkt auf eine ganz andere Ebene heben.
Ja, das ist so dieses Was bedeutet überhaupt Souveränität?
Was kann wahre Souveränität? Niemand hat von Souveränität geredet. Bewusst nicht.
Wir haben von Digital Independence geredet. Dann kommt aber,
ja Moment, da gibt es immer einen kolonialen Hintergrund und das finde ich jetzt
aber problematisch, dass hier irgendwie,
Deutschland wurde ja gar nicht kolonialisiert und damit beschmutzt ihr ja das
Andenken der ganzen Kolonialisierten, wir müssen ja dekolonialisieren.
Alles richtig, alles richtig.
Der entscheidende Punkt ist natürlich, Deutschland hat sich in dieser Abhängigkeit
selber begeben, stimmt auch und die Menschen haben frei gewählt,
sind alle zu WhatsApp gesagt, ist ja alles richtig.
Heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass wir jetzt nicht sagen, wir nutzen trotzdem eine Alternative.
Und ich kann dem, ich kann...
Dem nicht so viel abgewinnen, weil ich da so unglaublich wenig,
konstruktives Moment erkenne, was ich irgendwie sexy finde.
Jetzt nur in dem Fundamentalismus oder in allen drei Varianten?
Wahrscheinlich gibt es noch viel mehr Varianten, dafür zu argumentieren,
dass man jetzt bloß nichts machen sollte und dass jeder, der irgendetwas macht,
naiv, doof, falsch, falsche Richtung und so weiter.
Ich wäre nur immer dann ganz gerne, würde ich sehen, was die Alternative der Leute ist.
Und die ist dann nämlich immer im Konjunktiv formuliert.
Und der Konjunktiv ist so ein Marker für, der häufigste Satz ist,
eigentlich müsste mal jemand. Das heißt schon mal so, wird nicht passieren,
wäre aber richtig und ich mach's nicht.
Und das ist halt alles so, Sachen bleiben, wie sie sind.
Und alles, was am Ende dahin lenkt, führt halt auch zu keiner Veränderung.
Und ja, wahrscheinlich wird das noch ein bisschen dauern, bis so ganz Deutschland
migriert ist, ja, da wird noch ein bisschen, da zieht sich noch hin.
Aber auch das hatte ich ja in der letzten Sendung hoffentlich gesagt,
dass eine kleine Community und damit eine größere Community migriert oder sich
einen anderen Default setzt und dann vielleicht irgendwann,
was weiß ich, vielleicht ist es auch nicht, dass ihr WhatsApp deinstalliert,
sondern einfach nur beim nächsten Handykauf nicht mehr installiert, weil ihr es vergesst.
Alle diese Wege sind ja da.
Wenn man einen Schritt geht und mal irgendwas anderes macht.
Jetzt haben wir das diesmal im Beispiel WhatsApp gemacht. LinkedIn kann übrigens auch...
Ich finde ja jetzt, also ich finde jetzt so eine reine Erreichbarkeit ist nicht
das eigentliche Problem.
Ich bin auch über WhatsApp zu erreichen.
Weil es halt einfach passiert, dass Kommunikation darüber mit mir aufgenommen
wird oder in irgendeiner Form auch mal darüber stattfinden muss.
Das ist falsch.
Welche der drei Kategorien waren das jetzt?
Es ist universal falsch.
Nee, es ist einfach eine Realität.
Tim, es gibt keine richtige Erreichbarkeit im falschen Messenger.
Der eigene Default zählt. Was ist es, was man sozusagen nach außen trägt,
was schlägt man vor und darüber kann man Dinge regeln.
Da wird sich auch keine einheitliche Situation daraus ergeben,
weil gerade in dieser Fundamentalistenlage gibt es schon allein das Rima und
das Signal und da kann sich ja auch keiner auf irgendwas einigen.
Nein, Matrix sind Matrix.
Matrix, oh Gott. Ja, also das ist auch am Ende nicht so wichtig.
Es ist halt nur, diese Kampagne soll einfach die Debatte starten,
dass es überhaupt erstmal eine gibt darüber, dass überhaupt erstmal so ein bisschen
Mindshare geschaffen wird, dass das ein Aspekt ist.
Neben all diesen anderen Zwängen, neben all den anderen Notwendigkeiten,
Dann gibt es halt auch noch diesen Aspekt,
nämlich wovon macht mich das abhängig und will ich das und brauche ich diese
Abhängigkeit wirklich und daraus kann man dann seine Defaults ableiten und dann
ergibt sich der Rest eigentlich von alleine.
So, kommen wir zum Thema der Woche. Thema der Woche.
Womit haben sich alle beschäftigt? Mit Grog?
Ja, Linus, ich habe hier ein Foto von dir im Bikini.
Ich bin doch gar nicht bei Grog.
Muss ja auch nicht sein.
Ich habe Twitter deinstalliert.
Die einfachen Quick Wins habe ich am ersten Dit gemacht.
Elon Musks Plattform X wird ja augmented oder ich weiß noch nicht mal wie das
da, aber man kann da Sachen mit Grog machen.
Grog ist so ein AI-Ding und irgendwie hat sich eine Funktionalität oder so ein
Trend ergeben, dass man Grog,
dieses AI-Ding anweist, Bilder zu verändern und was da jetzt sehr häufig passiert
ist, dass man sagt, stelle diese Person eben in sehr knapp bekleidet dar. Und.
Was beim ersten Blick vielleicht einfach nur ein bisschen, ja das kommt vielleicht
so ein bisschen doof daher oder so und dann denkst du, was soll das?
Höhöhöhöhöh. Weiß nicht, Donald Trump in Unterhose.
Das hat natürlich, wenn du das jetzt mal wirklich in seiner Wirkung auch auf
ein Individuum bewährt ist, einen sehr,
viel stärkeren Impact als man vielleicht als unbeteiligte betrachtende Person,
die das bei einer Prominenten sieht und dann einfach nur vielleicht auf den
ersten Blick denkt, ach das ist aber irgendwie ein kindischer Quatsch hier.
Es gibt einen guten Grund, warum sowas in,
breiten Internetforen halt eigentlich unterbunden wird.
Weil das insbesondere, wenn es dann Menschen betrifft, die nicht prominent sind
und du das mit denen genauso machst, eben einfach nur eine sexualisierte Gewalt ist.
Nämlich die nackt oder annähernd nackt oder in aufreizenden Posen Darstellung
einer Person, die dieses Bild nicht nur nicht in der Öffentlichkeit haben möchte,
noch dazu es noch nicht einmal erstellt hat, ja, das heißt sie war noch nicht
einmal in der Situation, in der sie da dargestellt wird, ja,
also offene, wenn du darüber nachdenkst, ist das eigentlich sogar….
Und fast genauso schlimm oder nicht minder schlimm, wie die Veröffentlichung
eines echten Bildes einer Person, in dem du dann ihre Privatsphäre verletzt
und irgendein privates Foto veröffentlichen würdest.
In dem Fall wurde dieses Foto noch nicht mal gemacht.
Das heißt, unter Umständen ist es sogar eine Situation, die da dargestellt ist,
in die die Person sich freiwillig gar nicht begeben wollte, die für sie selber
sogar unangenehm ist. Zum Beispiel, wenn Donald Trump, weiß man gar nicht,
ob der im pinken Bikini rumrennt oder nicht.
Da muss man auf jeden Fall Konsent einholen.
So und jetzt ist das auf einmal so ein Breitensport, wird natürlich kritisiert.
Elon Musk hat dann sich darüber lustig gemacht, indem man ein Bild von sich
selber im Bikini gepostet hat.
Ich glaube aus einer würde man würde man sagen, dass Elon Musk ein privilegierter,
Mensch ist, ja ne als reichster Mensch der Erde ist er wahrscheinlich das eine oder andere Privileg,
und hat dann gesagt, ja pass auf, wenn das für mich kein Problem ist,
dann hat es für euch auch keins zu sein sicherlich für viele Nutzerinnen und
natürlich konzentriert sich das auf Nutzerinnen weil nicht ganz so viele Leute
Donald Trump nackt sehen wollen.
Und das hat sich dann natürlich, wurde und ich denke zu Recht zu einem sehr, sehr großen Thema.
Ein Sprecher von X hat dann gesagt, ja pass auf, das Generieren und Verbreiten
illegaler Inhalte hat die gleichen Konsequenzen für die Accounts,
als würden sie die Inhalte selbst erstellen und verbreiten.
Das ist auch ein lustiger Punkt, wenn du mithilfe von der AI,
die wir dir bereitstellen, die das dann macht, illegale Inhalte erstellst,
beispielsweise sexualisierte Deepfakes und damit sexualisierte Gewalt an Menschen.
Dann bist du dafür verantwortlich. Es ist auch eine, ich bin mal gespannt,
weil irgendwo dazwischen wird es auf jeden Fall sein.
Am Ende wird so eine Globalregulierung da sein, dass am Ende dann der Mensch
dann noch verantwortlich ist.
Aber hier ist ja eine Plattform, die das Feature offensiv im Prinzip entwickelt
hat und sogar die Viralität seiner Nutzung bewirbt.
Das glaube ich, vor dem Hintergrund ist diese Äußerung ein bisschen zynisch.
Um es auf dieser Plattform zu verbreiten und nicht nur es zu generieren.
Ja, EU und verschiedene Länder überprüfen sie jetzt, wie sie damit umgehen.
Klingt ein bisschen nach, Twitter will noch eine Digital Services Act Strafe haben.
Dann habe ich gelesen im Artikel von Anna Biseli, Malaysia und Indonesien haben
den Chatbot am Wochenende sperren lassen.
Dann habe ich gedacht, okay, wie haben die das denn hingekriegt?
Weil der Chatbot-Grog ist einerseits direkt erreichbar, aber der hat eben auch
diese Twitter-Integration,
X-Integration und ja, der scheint auch eben löchrig zu sein, diese Sperre.
Also es gibt da irgendwie, du kannst nicht mehr direkt auf Grog zugreifen oder
so und sie erzwingen jetzt quasi,
Änderungen, aber trotzdem sind natürlich diese Bilder noch postbar und irgendwie,
wenn man direkt über bestimmte Webseiten vermittelt, darauf zugreift,
funktioniert es trotzdem.
Aber die haben wenigstens schon mal direkt gesagt, das werden wir so nicht mehr akzeptieren.
Und die EU überlegt sich auch, ob sie da im Allverfahren gegen vorgehen.
Was dann natürlich auch zurecht bemängelt wird, ist, die Diskussion darüber
führen dann die genannten Politikerinnen über Twitter.
Das wäre auch vielleicht so ein Ding.
Ja, das ist nicht die feine Art, direkt über den Tatort rüber zu latschen.
Ich bin ähm,
Bisschen erstaunt, unschöne Ecken des Internets gab es ja schon immer.
Die guten alten Imageboards und wo ja auch wirklich, also es wird ja immer relativ
schnell im Internet irgendwo eine Ecke gefunden,
wo man sicherstellt, dass jede Grenze des Geschmacks sofort penetriert wird.
In so bestimmten kompletten Assiräumen und so ist das vielleicht auch mal,
naja, vielleicht könnte man in einem gewissen Maße argumentieren,
dass das auch eine kleine Katharsis ist oder sowas, die da stattfindet leider
haben wir die Erfahrung damit gemacht,
dass diese 4chants und 8chants früher oder später dann eben zu sehr
unangenehmen sozialen Phänomenen und Entwicklungen führen.
Und wenn man jetzt sowas hier in der Breite auf so einer großen und ich denke
ja dann doch maßgeblichen Plattform wie Twitter macht und geschehen lässt,
dann hat das potenziell noch sehr viel unschönere,
soziale Auswirkungen, was das für die Betroffenen bedeutet.
Also wenn du da irgendwie durch so ein 4chan oder 8chan oder wie auch immer
das dann aktuell heißt, hoch und runter gereicht wirst, ist das schon schlimm genug?
Ja, wenn es auf einer großen weltweiten Plattform mit vielen,
vielen, vielen Millionen Nutzerinnen ist, wie X, dann ist das nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension.
Ja, es ist einfach, die Frage ist, was macht man jetzt dagegen?
Also macht man was dagegen und wenn ja, was macht man denn dagegen?
Und ich meine, dass Sie hier an dieser Stelle jegliche Sorgfaltspflicht unterlassen,
ist ja nun sehr offensichtlich. Und man sieht ja auch, wie politisch das aufgeladen ist.
Also wenn selbst, klingt jetzt gleich ein bisschen blöd, aber warum ist denn
sozusagen sowas noch nicht aus dem App Store geflogen?
Sowohl bei Google als auch bei Apple.
Und meine liest du ja mal so die Bedingungen durch, die da drin stehen,
so Verstöß gegen alles, also es ist halt einfach.
Auf jeder Ebene, also so Porno-Apps und all dieser ganze Kram,
ja das darf nicht irgendwie da sein, aber jetzt so eine App,
die irgendwie dann vielleicht noch in den Top Ten,
steht, wo man dann sozusagen all diesen ganzen Scheiß generieren kann,
wo die Plattform offen dafür wirbt und jeder weiß es und alle reden darüber
und es ist in den News, So und das ist aber jetzt noch keinem aufgefallen.
Kann mir ja keiner erzählen.
Ja und dann wissen wir natürlich sofort, was der Grund ist. Der Grund ist der,
dass einfach da ein politisches Drohpotenzial aufgebaut worden ist,
was offensichtlich wirkt.
In Europa, also in den USA jetzt natürlich. Bei uns ist es, weiß ich nicht, nicht ganz so.
Ich meine, hier gäbe es natürlich durchaus die Einsicht, sag ich mal,
dass das jetzt nicht passt.
Die Frage ist, was wird konkret getan, wie schnell und über welchen Mechanismus?
Ist es jetzt nur Strafen oder gehen wir jetzt eben auch schon auf den Level des Sperrens?
Ja,
das, also ich würde Strafen bevorzugen.
Ich man könnte aber natürlich schon sagen, ich meine wenn du eine Maschine baust,
die explizit quasi eine Funktionalität der,
rechte Verletzungen anderer Menschen hat und das auch noch viral mit umgeht,
dann muss man sich schon, irgendwann kommst du vielleicht schon an den Punkt, wo du sagst, naja,
als derjenige, der das in die Welt setzt, hast du da auch eine Verantwortung
für und kannst nicht sagen, das sind jetzt die User.
Es ist doch so absurd. Die Politik in Europa hat uns jetzt irgendwie jahrzehntelang
erzählt, dass all dieser ganze böse Kram, den sie verbieten wollen,
ja, alles wegen Kinderpornografie.
So.
Jetzt gibt es hier so einen Anbieter, der sagt, ja, hier, Kinderpornografie
selbst gemacht. Kommt alle.
Und was machen die Politiker? Sie benutzen dieses Tool, um sich über etwas anderes zu unterhalten.
Und das ist sozusagen der Grund, warum sie alle auf, ich meine,
ich verstehe das ja auch, also wenn du jetzt diese populäre Forderung mit nutz
doch bitte X nicht, die haben ja genau dasselbe Problem. weil die Politik...
Und die Krisenkommunikation und diese politische Debatte auf sozialen Medien
unter Politikern und anderen Denkern, Kommentatoren, Journalisten und so weiter,
die findet ja auch nach wie vor auf dieser Plattform statt. Das ist ja das Absurde.
Trotzdem sind sie jetzt nicht in der Lage, hier eins und eins zusammen zu zählen
und zu sagen, naja, vielleicht sollten wir mal woanders hingehen.
Warum machen sie es nicht? Aus denselben Gründen, die wir vorhin auch schon
diskutiert haben, weil sie da einfach nicht independent sind.
Also es gibt da einfach keine Alternative.
Und keiner will dann dieses brennende Schiff verlassen.
Ja und damit legitimieren sie es weiter und damit erhält so etwas Einzug in
die Mittel der Gesellschaft.
Ich muss einen Fehler korrigieren, den ich gerade gemacht habe.
Und zwar habe ich gerade gesagt, in dem Artikel von Anna Biseli,
das ist kein Artikel von Anna Biseli, das ist ein Artikel von Laura Jaruszewski.
Und das sehe ich, sie ist gerade Praktikantin bei Netzpolitik.org und ich hoffe,
dass sie es mir nicht übel nimmt, dass ich sie mit der Chefredakteurin verwechselt
habe in ihrem Artikel, aber ja, sorry, weil das,
wäre jetzt, hat mir jetzt leid, hätte mir leid getan, dass ich das nicht direkt...
Können wir den vom Gehalt abziehen?
Ja, genau. Von meinem Praktikantengehalt.
Ich war ja auch mal Praktikant bei Netzpolitik.org, insofern Gruß an die Kollegen.
Ja, gut.
Bleiben wir bei AI.
Das ist ein spannendes Thema auch.
Also die ENISA, das ist die EU-Agentur für,
Cyber-Geschichten. Information Security. Ich bin gerade am überlegen,
wofür überhaupt ENISA steht. European.
Kannst du mal kurz gucken?
ENISA. European Agency for Cyber Security.
Warum kommt da jetzt Cyber nicht drin?
Oi, ja. Lese ich da eher. Ja, okay. Das ist kein Akronym.
Heißt einfach mal ENISA und reimt sich nicht.
Ja, es ist eine,
Abkürzung des Originalnamens. Agency of the European Union ist wahrscheinlich
die französische Variante.
Ist wahrscheinlich französisch, ne?
Genau.
Okay, also Europäische Behörde für Cybersicherheit, die machen ähnlich wie das,
BSI, schreiben die auch so einen Gefahrenlagebericht.
Wo sie sagen, so was hier, was im Cyberraum los, ne?
Und den machen sie einmal so für, ich glaube, so allgemein, aber sie haben dann
auch nochmal so spezifizierte für einzelne Bereiche. So, und die haben,
diese Dinger veröffentlicht und in dem Gefahren Lagebericht,
Stehen allerhand spannende Dinge drin. Sagen, ja hier die Hacker,
nehmen dir die Passwörter weg und wenn die das demnächst mit AI machen,
dann wird das noch gefährlicher.
Und dann haben Leute von der Westfälischen Hochschule, und zwar insbesondere
der Christian Dietrich und der Raphael Springer,
haben diesen Bericht gelesen.
Was ja schon erstaunlich ist. Das ist eigentlich schon mal eine Meldung,
dass jemand das Ding liest.
Das ist die erste, das ist das erste Ding.
Das ist eigentlich nicht vorgesehen.
Jetzt haben die aber noch, jetzt haben die richtig Unexpected User Behavior
gezeigt und haben gesagt, da steht was, das kommt mir komisch vor,
da ist eine Fußnote, da ist ein Link, da klicke ich doch mal drauf.
Und dann kam 404.
Hat sich wohl einer vertippt?
Da muss sich wohl einer vertippt haben. Dann haben sie weitergelesen,
haben gesehen, hier ist der Nummer, den klicke ich da auch mal drauf, auch 404.
Und dann haben sie das Ding, ich glaube es waren zwei Reports,
geprüft und von 492 Links gingen 26 ins Nichts.
Also zu einer 404-Fehlermeldung.
Es waren auch nicht nur die Links, kam auch die Schlussfolgerung in diesem Bericht
ein bisschen komisch vor.
Ja, genau. Also deswegen klickst du ja überhaupt auf die Referenz und denkst
dir, wo habt ihr das denn her?
Ja, es steht ein bisschen komisch vor.
Da will ich mal ganz kurz gucken, was ist denn die Primärquelle O404?
Bevor wir auflösen, löse ich noch was anderes auf. European Network and Information
Security Agency. Ah, ja.
Was ist jetzt die Auflösung von all dieser komischen Geschichten?
Dann haben sie erstmal gesagt, was haben wir denn hier für Links?
Dann haben sie katalogisiert und dann haben sie geguckt, okay,
gibt es die in der Wayback Machine?
Als ich die Liste der Links dann irgendwann mal hatte, habe ich außerdem nochmal
geguckt, ob man Seiten findet, die dorthin linken.
Ob es den Link irgendwo anders als Link gibt.
Hat es den Link mal gegeben und glücklicherweise sind dann diese so Suchmaschinen,
die man das fragt, die sind so ein bisschen gracefuller.
Die sagen dann so, naja, okay, du hast da jetzt, da sind zwei,
drei Buchstaben zu groß drin, aber du meinst eigentlich den hier.
Also ein Link, der war tatsächlich, da waren quasi ein Großbuchstabe,
wo keiner hingehörte oder zwei.
Aber andere waren völlig absurd. Zum Beispiel, dass sie,
zu Microsoft linkten, also quasi eine Threat Intelligence Artikel von Microsoft,
und in dem Link stand ja hier der APT29 Report von Microsoft.
Was die Bezeichnung einer Hackergruppe ist.
Genau, was die Hackergruppe Advanced Persistent Threat mit der Nummer 29 ist,
die allerdings von Microsoft nicht APT29 genannt wird, sondern Midnight Blizzard.
Das heißt, es ist wirklich extrem unwahrscheinlich, dass es jemals einen Microsoft-Link
geben würde, wo APT29 drin vorkommt, wenn von Midnight Blizzard die Rede ist.
Ja, dann haben sie das mal, haben sie die Agentur mal konfrontiert,
weil es relativ klar war, dass diese Links wahrscheinlich herbeihalluziniert wurden.
Und das wäre ja dann mal interessant, wie das denn passiert ist.
Und dann haben die Antwort war,
ja, also es gab kleinere redaktionelle Überarbeitungen und bei dieser Gelegenheit
wären die Links verfälscht worden von der bösen Lektorin.
So, ehrlich gesagt, ich halte das für...
Also mich würde auf jeden Fall mal interessieren, welche KI das war und welches
Prompt die der denn gegeben haben, weil ich zumindest kenne kein Modell,
was so mir nichts, dir nichts, einfach mal einen Link verändert.
Vielleicht doch?
Doch, klar. Ich meine, die denken sich das ja auch alles aus.
Okay, dann also vielleicht habe ich da zu wenig Vibe-Coding und Prompting-Erfahrung.
Jedenfalls, auf jeden Fall hat ja dann hier keine ordentliche Qualitätskontrolle stattgefunden.
Entsprechend schieben sie es auch auf einen menschlichen Fehler.
Ob der menschliche Fehler jetzt nur darin bestanden hat, eine kleinere redaktionelle
Überarbeitung nicht genau zu prüfen oder vielleicht doch noch,
ein größeres Ausmaß von menschlichem Fehler da beteiligt war,
haben sich jetzt nicht so geäußert.
Aber Tim, sie haben ja jetzt einen neuen Report veröffentlicht,
in dem das korrigiert ist.
Und?
Da kann man dann mal gucken. Und ich habe das jetzt mal hier gediffed,
beziehungsweise, tatsächlich blicke ich nicht auf einen Diff,
den ich gemacht habe, sondern den hat Kantorkel gemacht, der ja auch schon zu.
Gast war und auch Sprecher des CCC ist.
Bei dem No, da gibt es einen Link zu NoBefore, das war der, den ich auch vorher
schon identifiziert hatte, dass da einfach nur ein quasi Groß-Kleinschreibungsproblem drin war.
Dann gibt es einen zu...
Yizet, da ist tatsächlich, ja, da wurde der Link in seiner Struktur geändert, also okay,
da musste noch ein Business Topics und Thread Landscape davor,
ja, das ist noch erklärbar, also es ist immerhin noch die gleiche Quelle.
Und dann kommen aber halt auch so Sachen wie okay, France TV Info wird korrigiert zu France Info,
okay, das sind auch noch ja, also es ist eine unschöne Veränderung aber ja,
okay, aber dann kommen so Sachen wie, vorher war der Link zum,
ncsc.gov UK, also die britische National Cyber Security Council oder was das ist.
Und danach geht er zu media.defense.gov also mit komplett anderer Text,
andere Inhalte, andere Formulierungen,
und auch wirklich halt statt britischer Cyber Organisation jetzt eine US-Cyber Organisation.
Aber ist dieser Diff jetzt nur auf den Links oder ist das jetzt ein Diff über das ganze Dokument?
Der Diff ist über das gesamte Dokument, deswegen muss ich da auch so durchscrollen,
weil die Seitenzahlen haben sich auch geändert.
Also 12 Uhr durch 13, 14, 15 aber natürlich kann man im Diff dann eben sehen,
hier da gibt es einen Link, der ging vorher zu blog.google und jetzt geht er
zu ic3.gov und da bei diesen Links ist es dann doch so ein bisschen,
unwahrscheinlich dass das eine AI geändert hat,
also ja peinlich,
bezahlen wir dafür als europäische Steuerzahler? Weil das ist ja das eigentliche Thema hier.
Da haben wir eine Cyberagentur auf EU-Ebene, die wir dafür bezahlen,
dass sie irgendwie einen 80-90-seitigen Bericht schreibt.
Und dann ist das letztendlich so ein AI-Slop. Finde ich ja schon ein bisschen.
Haben wir wohl nicht genug bezahlt, ne?
Genau, dem müssen wir mehr Geld geben.
Die haben schon ein ganz ordentliches Budget.
Natürlich leidet da die Glaubwürdigkeit dieser Institutionen.
Finde ich schon ein bisschen sehr peinlich.
Also 26,2 Millionen Euro in 2024.
Okay, ist jetzt nicht so viel, aber ich frage mich, wenn die halt in ihrem Signature-Piece,
das ist ja immer noch dieser Threat-Landscape-Report,
das wird im Zweifelsfall das sein, was noch am meisten Leute lesen,
nämlich zwei Leute an der Westfälischen Hochschule schon mal mindestens.
Und dann wahrscheinlich ein paar AIs, die daraus die DPA-Meldung machen,
Cyber ist ein Problem dann Hakan Tanriverdi der den Artikel geschrieben hat,
aber was ist denn wenn man bei den anspruchsvolleren Detailarbeiten ich meine,
die schreiben ja auch geben ja Ratschläge zu irgendwie, wie Gesetzgebung was ist ein Problem,
wie müssen wir diesen Cyberraum jetzt regulieren was müssen wir jetzt endlich
mal erlauben, verbieten oder sonst was,
ist die nächste Liste, die irgendjemand
abhaken muss, damit das Cyber-Sicherheit endlich kommt und so.
Das ist halt ein Experten-Gremium, was wir uns da unterhalten und wenn deren,
größte Veröffentlichung, deren reichweitenstärkste Veröffentlichung auf so zweifelhafte
Weise zustande kommt, dann fragt man sich natürlich, oder kann man sich die
Frage stellen, was denn mit dem Rest ist, den die so formulieren.
Ja, ich meine, es liegt natürlich so ein bisschen der Verdacht nahe,
dass sie sich ein bisschen Arbeit gespart haben, weil sie dachten,
den Scheiß liest am Ende sowieso keiner.
Das ändert sich auch.
Und das mag auch oft so sein bei solchen Berichten, dass keiner liest,
aber das hat alles so seine Grenzen.
Also den Scheiß liest keiner. Es hat sich eigentlich auch nichts geändert.
Und es zieht auch keiner die Lehren draus. Also sonst wäre ja nicht,
also ich meine, die arme BSI, die müssen auch jedes Jahr das Lage der Cybersicherheit, ja.
Man nehme ein Blatt Papier und male es rot. Ja, also es wären ja keine Lehren daraus gezogen.
Insofern kann ich schon vorstellen, dass man sich sagt, ja komm Alter,
hier mach mal Chachibitikum, schreib mal für dieses Jahr.
Nimm mal bitte den alten Artikel und ersetz mal alle Jahreszahlen 25 durch 26
und dann brechen halt ein paar Links.
Tja, wenn wir das machen würden.
Das würde den Leuten garantiert nicht auffallen.
Meinst du?
Wenn wir jetzt hier einfach mal eine Logbuch-Netzpolitik von vor zehn Jahren
und dann reden wir über also das Einzige, was auffällt, ist,
dass wir nicht so viel über AI reden.
Naja, weiß ich nicht, ob das dann der Fall wäre. Also es gibt ja schon so AIs,
die so komplette Podcasts produzieren.
Dann wirfst du einfach die News rein und dann werden unsere Stimmen imitiert
und dann können wir hier auch so uns mal so unterhalten.
Ja, weißt du, Linus, da ist mir dann noch eine Geschichte untergekommen.
Das war wirklich interessant.
Oh, und was? Wenn wir euch hier irgendwann mal zu happy vorkommen,
als hätte der Tim irgendwie zwei Happy-Pilz zu viel, dann guckt einfach,
ob in den Shownotes die Links stimmen.
Das ist dann unser...
Dann wisst ihr Bescheid.
Dann wisst ihr, die AI-Overlords haben wir uns doch gekriegt.
Genau. Wir liegen hier wahrscheinlich gefesselt auf dem Boden der Meta-Ebene.
Wobei, wenn wir da vorbeikommen. Mit deinem Vibe-Coding, Show-Note-Generation-Skript
habe ich auch noch Angst, dass da irgendwann nochmal die...
Ja, da kann man sich nicht sicher sein.
Da weiß man auch nicht, wo wir da irgendwie hinlegen. Klickt besser nicht unsere Links.
Gut.
Ja, ein Thema, zu dem ich gerade mehrere Presseanfragen bekommen habe,
die ich nicht beantworten konnte, weil ich einfach zu viel zu tun hatte, um mich da einzulesen.
Ja.
Im Iran gibt es ja sowieso gerade eine irre Situation, starke Proteste,
die aber auch denen mit einer extremen Gewalt begegnet wird.
Offensichtlich, ja.
Und eine unklare Informationslage, oder widersprüchliche Informationslage, weil?
Internet abgeschaltet. Internet abgeschaltet, genau. Also der Irak hat ja… Iran. Entschuldigung.
Iran hat ohnehin so ein hybrides System, so richtiges Internet und nationales Internet sozusagen.
Das nationale Internet ist halt einfach kappbar und darauf haben die Leute in
der Regel nur den Zugriff und wenn man halt richtig Internet haben will,
muss man in irgendeiner Form einen Weg nach draußen finden.
Dieses kappbare Internet ist jetzt auch seit Tagen gekappt und es sieht halt
ganz danach aus, dass derzeit einfach massenhaft Leute umgebracht werden auf den Straßen.
Es gibt halt diese Proteste, das verfolgt ja sicherlich alles in den Nachrichten
ohnehin. Darüber kann ich jetzt genauso wenig sagen, weil wir wissen es ja nicht.
Es gibt halt hier und da Berichte, die noch so durchstechen.
Unser gemeinsamer bekannter Enno hat einen Artikel veröffentlicht auf seinem Blog,
der mal ganz interessant ist, weil er sozusagen die Situation schildert wie
vor allem im kurdischen Bereich,
das ist ja auch der nördliche Teil Irans Kurdistan ist ja quasi über Iran,
Türkei Irak verteilt,
und dementsprechend gibt es da halt gute Grenzbeziehungen und darüber wird sicherlich
das eine oder andere reingeschmuggelt und ja,
die einzige Möglichkeit derzeit im Iran nennenswert an Internet ranzukommen
ist halt Starlink und diese Starlink-Schüsseln werden halt über diese Grenze
schon seit längerer Zeit rübergeschmuggelt,
sodass es halt immer mal wieder Orte gibt im Iran,
wo Leute dann doch eben die Möglichkeit haben, an diesem,
nationalen Internetverbund vorbei ins Netz zu gehen und das ist natürlich in
der aktuellen Situation die einzige Möglichkeit jetzt ist es aber auch so,
dass im Iran auch das Starlink,
geblockt wird und das ist ganz interessant das beschreibt nämlich Enno wie das
so bisher so lief also Jammer, wir hatten ja diese Diskussion hier auch schon
mal mit Jamming und Spoofing,
Im Kontext dieser ganzen Marine-Situation und so weiter.
Du hast einen Vortrag auch drüber beim Kongress.
Über Alternativen im baltischen Raum. Das meinst du.
Hier geht es aber im Wesentlichen um Jamming. Das heißt, was der Iran oder die
iranische Regierung macht, ist, dass sie diese Starlink-Frequenzen zu jammen.
Das machen sie wohl auch schon seit einiger Zeit.
Und die Lösung dagegen war, dass man
die Starlink-Antennen mit so großen Heizrohren, also wie man das so von,
Klimatisierungsrohren kennt, also mit diesem großen Durchmesser,
dass man die Starlink-Schüsseln mit diesen großen Rohren umgibt,
sodass diese Schüsseln nur Signale empfangen, die jetzt wirklich auch von oben kommen.
Also.
Und nicht von der Seite gejabbt werden.
Damit das Signal von der Seite, was gemmen soll, da möglichst nicht hinkommt.
Genau, also Gemma aufbauen, das geht natürlich leicht.
Und durch diesen Trick war es wohl möglich, diesen terrestrischen Gemmern weitgehend zu entkommen.
Das schränkt natürlich dann auch deine Leistungsfähigkeit ein.
Weil der ja nicht mehr so gut den Satelliten folgen kann.
Genau, aber Starling ist auch relativ gut da drin, solche kurzfristigen Abbrüche
relativ smooth zu umgehen.
Dann kommen zwar mal keine Daten, aber kaum das wieder ein Satellit gesehen
wird, dann nimmt es auch die Kommunikation wieder ziemlich gut auf.
Jetzt ist es allerdings so, dass auch das wohl nur noch eingeschränkt funktioniert,
weil sie mittlerweile das Jamming von Drohnen ausmachen.
Das heißt, sie starten tatsächlich Drohnen, die also dann Jamming-Signale von
oben nach unten schicken, um eben auch noch diese Kommunikation zu unterbrechen.
Das ist ein ganz interessanter Artikel, ist verlinkt, findet ihr in den Shownotes.
Ich wollte das einfach auch nochmal hier reinnehmen, um erstmal klarzumachen,
welchen Aufwand mittlerweile Regierungen bereit sind zu betreiben,
wenn es darum geht, ein Volk zu unterdrücken.
Und ihr macht hier Digital Detox. Überlegt euch mal.
Wer macht Digital Detox?
Die ganzen Leute im Januar, ja ich mach Digital Detox. Echt?
Sowas gibt's?
Ja, du machst sowas nicht.
Nee, was mach ich nicht? Ich bin verrückt. Das würde ich ja nicht überleben.
Aber das ist schon krass, oder? Die fliegen mit Drohnen rum,
um die Starlink-Dinger zu jammen.
Also die wollen halt wirklich nicht, dass jemand kommuniziert.
Die haben einfach jetzt Schiss, dass sie einfach komplett hops genommen werden
bei den Demonstrationen, weil das ist definitiv der stärkste Straßendruck,
den sie in den letzten Jahrzehnten gehabt haben.
Und es ist auch immer noch vollkommen offen, wie das jetzt umgeht.
Es gibt sehr beunruhigende Berichte, keine Ahnung, welche mehr stimmen und welche
weniger, von ein paar hundert Tote bis ein paar tausend Tote.
Und das sind aber auch teilweise nur Berichte aus einzelnen Städten.
Und es ist sehr offensichtlich ziemlich schlimm gerade dort.
Ja, ich meine, irgendwann wird auch dort das Internet wieder eingeschaltet werden müssen.
Also diese Nachrichten werden uns sowieso erreichen. Ich finde das jetzt insofern bemerkenswert,
als dass wir auf der einen Seite viel jetzt in letzter Zeit mitbekommen haben
darüber, wie das Internet bedrohlich ist für Gesellschaften.
Aber kein Internet ist auch bedrohlich für die Gesellschaft.
Was für ein Einschnitt. Aber wahrscheinlich, wenn...
Ja, man redet hier, also die Berichte gehen irgendwie in Richtung tausende Tote
und zehntausende Festnahmen.
Ja, ganz schlimm, dass sie sogar noch irgendwie in die Krankenhäuser gehen und
schauen, wer da Schusswunden hat und dann werden die auch nochmal gekillt.
Also es ist wirklich Apokalypse now. Also es ist wirklich schlimm.
Und man kann nur hoffen, dass es diesmal dazu führt, dass es wirklich einen
Regime-Change gibt im Iran, aber das kann glaube ich keiner sagen.
Trump redet viel heiße Luft den ganzen Tag.
Ey, hör mir auf mit Trump.
Ja, es ist absurd. Man verspricht den Unterstützung und es kommt keine,
weil er jetzt seinen ganzen Flugzeugträger alle nach Südamerika geschickt hat,
um da irgendwelche Diktatoren hops zu nehmen.
Der, was in dem Kontext jetzt wieder viel,
Verbreitung findet, das passiert dann immer so, wenn in großen Internetzensurwellen
oder so, dann wird gerne mal wieder zum Beispiel Snowflake beworben,
dass die meisten Menschen als Browser-Extension kennen, ist aber erstmal grundsätzlich
nicht notwendigerweise etwas, was unbedingt als Browser-Extension laufen kann, muss.
Das kannst du auch als Docker-Container oder als normales Binary auf deiner
Command-Line launchen.
Eine Tor-Entry-Node-System, was anders als die klassischen Tor-Entries oder
Tor-Server, die man irgendwo stehen hat,
halt versucht Protokolle und Handshakes zu verwenden, die eher wie Telefonate aussehen.
Und außerdem nicht darauf basieren,
dass man die komplette Anzahl Entry-Notes zum TOR-Netzwerk bekannt machen muss
und dadurch quasi das Sperren von TOR erschweren und das Erreichen von TOR ermöglicht
die Umgehung von Zensur.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit deine Regierung hat die Internetverbindungen zu anderen
Ländern gekappt und fliegt mit Drohnen übers Land um dein Starlink zu jammen da ist dann,
da gibt es dann doch etwas weniger,
Traffic.
Hilft natürlich nur, wenn man überhaupt erst mal Internet hat.
Eben, die brauchen dann immer noch Internet. Aber klar, Enno beschreibt ja auch
hier, dass es, als sie noch Internet hatten, da hätte der das machen müssen.
Insofern freue ich mich immer solche Wellen, wenn dann darauf hingewiesen wird,
dass man solche Tools nutzen kann.
Und wenn man irgendwo, keine Ahnung, Wenn man so ein Raspberry Pi rumstehen
hat oder zu Hause auf dem NAS,
irgendwas was immer an ist und man möchte was Gutes tun, dann ist ein sauber
konfigurierter Snowflake Proxy da drauf sicherlich was Nettes.
Aufpassen, muss eventuell noch ein paar Weiterleitungen einrichten,
wenn man nuttet und sowas, aber kann man halt machen.
Aber das sollte man dann einfach auch immer anlassen und nicht nur,
weil es gerade wieder im Fernsehen ist, dass irgendwas abgeschaltet oder zensiert wird.
Das lohnt sich sowas dauerhaft zu betreiben. Ich habe das, viele Jahre lang
habe ich Tor-Infrastruktur betrieben,
in kleinem Maßstab, inzwischen machen es große Vereine in großen Stückzahlen,
aber so diese Entry-Proxys,
so ein Snowflake mal irgendwo laufen zu lassen, kann man durchaus mal tun.
Hat übrigens, anders als der Betrieb eines Exits, auch keine Risiken.
Also wenn du einen Exit betreibst, dann bist du ja die IP-Adresse,
auf die zurückverfolgt wird, wenn mal was Böses getan wurde.
Das heißt, das möchte man lieber als einen Verein machen, der quasi eine rechtliche
Basis hat und sagt, wir betreiben hier eine Nominationsinfrastruktur und unsere
Vereinsräume sind da hinten, wenn sie die durchsuchen wollen.
Aber so ein Snowflake kann man grundsätzlich einfach mal betreiben.
Aber hilft zumindest jetzt den Menschen im Iran gerade nicht.
Was auch nicht heißt, dass man es jetzt wieder abschalten soll,
weil hoffentlich werden die bald wieder Internet haben.
Idealerweise einfach ein unzensiertes, freies.
Sollte das vorübergehend noch nicht der Fall sein, dann freuen die sich unter Umständen.
What's next?
What is next?
Ja, während wir uns freuen, dass die Chat-Kontrolle abgewendet wurde,
hat Großbritannien jetzt ein Gesetz erlassen,
nee, ist in Kraft getreten, hatten sie es natürlich schon, dass die Anbieter
von Social Media und Dating-Diensten untersuchen müssen, was die Leute sich
da gegenseitig zuschicken.
Und zwar geht es dabei um die Vermeidung von, jetzt würdest du eigentlich Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen
sagen, nee, es geht um Vermeidung von Dickpics.
Also immerhin, das ist die Meldung, das ist meine andere Story hier für ein
komplett Überwachungssystem.
Ein bisschen Abwechslung in die Diskussion.
Und zwar in Großbritannien haben sogar einen Begriff dafür das heißt,
Cyberflashing Ja.
Wenn man sozusagen digital einen raushängen lässt Ich bin.
Also das ist etwas, was ich ein kleiner Exkurs das habe ich nie verstanden,
und Ende zu Ende Mir fehlt Ende zu Ende vollständig das Verständnis für den
Vorgang. Für den Vorgang.
Warum man das überhaupt tun würde. Ja.
Noch dazu mit einer Person, die man nicht kennt oder die man kennt,
die man damit absichtlich verstören oder erniedrigen möchte.
Erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht,
Ist nicht in meinem Repertoire von,
Erniedrigungsfantasien. Ich hab's einfach. Ich hab es nicht in mir.
Aber wenn ich eigentlich wann immer ich da mal mit Frauen, die beispielsweise
auf Dating-Plattformen oder so waren, rede, die sagen halt, das passiert am laufenden Band.
Ähm.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das so primär unbedingt immer Erniedrigungsfantasien sind.
Die das auslösen. Vielleicht will mich niemand erniedrigen. Ich kriege auch keine Dickpics.
Achso.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein britischer.
Ich verstehe es nicht, aber das ist das auf jeden Fall kann ich aus meiner anekdotischen,
Evidenzerhebung sagen. es ist ein größeres Thema, als man meint.
Ja.
Und ich kann nur sagen...
Also als Männer meinen.
Ja, aber okay, also entweder gibt es einige wenige Männer, die ganz viele Dickpics
verschicken und dann sehr, sehr, sehr busy sind.
Oder es gibt mehr Männer, die das machen, als man denkt.
Und ich verstehe es nicht.
Ja, Aber it's a thing. Und dementsprechend wird jetzt auch was unternommen.
Genau, und was haben uns diese Wichser? Wichser sind nämlich Wichser.
Weißt du, was die Wichser uns eingebrockt haben?
Ja, die politische Maßnahmen, die jetzt ergriffen werden.
Das sind jetzt sozusagen die Folgen. Jetzt muss das nämlich alles überwacht werden. Hat UK gesagt.
Weil geht ja sonst nicht.
Social Media und Datingplattformen müssen künftig sämtliche Inhalte analysieren.
Auch und vor allem Inhalte, die Nutzerinnen sich gegenseitig senden,
bei denen also zuvor mindestens eine gewisse Vertraulichkeit angenommen werden konnte.
Und jetzt zitiere ich Martin Schwarzbeck. Immer noch nicht Anna Biseli, sorry.
Glück gehabt, dass ich nochmal geguckt habe. Ähm.
Und sie sagen, wenn sie es nicht machen, dann Geldstrafe bis zur Höhe von 10%
des weltweiten Umsatzes und mit einer Sperre in Großbritannien bestraft werden.
Ich würde sagen, das klingt für mich etwas über die, klingt als wenn die etwas
über das Ziel hinausschießen.
Und vor allem, dass man sagt, sie müssen scannen, ja, es müssten doch eigentlich,
andere Möglichkeiten sich geben, ja, ergeben das vielleicht zu machen.
Hier wird in dem Artikel von Martin zitiert, Bumble,
die haben eine sogenannte KI, die Bilder erkennt, auf denen nackte Haut zu sehen
ist und da wird dann unschärfisch filtert rübergelegt, dass die Leute das Bild
nicht sofort sehen, sondern quasi sagen können,
also es ist quasi so ein Sensitive-Filter drüber.
Ja, ich will jetzt sehen.
Das finde ich, damit werden dann eben Empfängerinnen vor dem Erhalt der Bilder gewarnt.
Das passiert übrigens auch, wenn dir eine unbekannte Person,
was weiß ich, auf dem Messenger deiner Wahl etwas schickt.
Bei Social Media gibt es teilweise so Flagging- Funktionen, die man zu Glück
auch wieder wegignorieren kann. Aber,
Ich weiß nicht, ob mir das Feature wert ist, dass eine zentrale Plattform alle
diese Bilder, die sie ja sowieso schon hat,
was ja schon mal schlecht ist, aber dass sie das dann auch noch mit einer KI analysiert.
Was ja, sagen wir mal, die einzige realistische Methode derzeit ist beim Stand
der Technologie, das ohne die Beschäftigung von tausenden von Mitarbeitern,
die dann auch nochmal alle traumatisiert werden, zu realisieren.
Ja, aber wenn man sagt, der Grauf, so ein Filter ist eine gute Idee,
dann kann man den ja auch einfach grundsätzlich über jedes eingehende Bild legen,
wenn man jetzt in, also als Userin oder als User, vielleicht,
nee, ich sag's lieber nicht, sonst krieg ich nachher noch irgendwelche Dickpics,
aber man könnte ja auch einfach sagen, okay, der Default von einer Hochrisikoplattform ist,
hier gibt's einen Schleier bei jedem Bild und die User können entscheiden, okay,
ich möchte diesen Schleier bei jedem Bild haben, ich will ihn nicht haben,
ganz kurz, was wäre die Konsequenz, wer auch immer da rum cyberflasht,
muss davon ausgehen, dass er seinen Effekt nicht erzielt, weil der Schleier der Default ist.
Und das könnte ausreichen, so meine Theorie, um dieses Verhalten zu zu grudgen.
Weiterhin, was auch helfen könnte, wäre wenn man diese Leute anzeigt und sie
der Strafverfolgung anheimfallen frage ich mich warum das nicht passiert müsste
man auch nochmal, also würde mich nochmal.
Interessieren was sind eigentlich die Strafen darauf wieso sagt man nicht zum
Beispiel auch okay pass auf, wenn du hier jemandem einen Dickpic schickst und
wir können das kontrollieren, wir haben nämlich einen Dickpic wir wissen,
zeig mal bitte dein Schnippel.
Das kann man ja relativ einfach, Beweisfoto hat man ja dann.
Warum sagt man nicht da, das kostet 10% des weltweiten Jahresumsatzes der Person.
Also ich bin, weißt du, ich weiß nicht, ob eine KI,
Filter Vorgabe für.
Ja, aber gerade diese Funktion würde ja das ach so meinst du dann,
wenn es dann gemeldet wird.
Nein, nein, nein.
Genau. Von den Empfängern.
So, gehen wir mal davon aus, eine Theorie, die sich für mich,
die mir irgendwie zumindest plausibler erscheint, als überhaupt,
dass man jemanden dadurch erniedrigen könnte, dass man ein Foto seines Genitals dahin schickt.
Vielleicht machen Menschen das auch freiwillig. Vielleicht sagen die auch,
naja okay, bevor ich die Reise nach Spandau auf mich nehme, würde ich gerne
wissen, was mich bei diesem Date erwartet.
Kann ja sein.
Ja, das ist möglich.
Es gibt die dollsten Dinge.
Ja.
So, und jetzt ist da so eine AI dazwischen und sagt,
ist ja auch scheiße. Also ich
glaube einfach nicht, dass das die richtige Lösung für das Problem ist.
Welche Lösung jetzt? Jetzt haben wir mehrere Sachen.
Dass Kommunikationsplattformen alle Inhalte mit einer AI scannen müssen.
Ja, naja gut, ich meine, wenn sie dann sozusagen das erstmal dann verschleiern
und du kannst dann immer noch das Angebot wahrnehmen.
Das ist ja meine Lösung, da brauchen
wir keine KI für. Einfach alles verschleiert, fertig ist die Laube.
Achso, na gut, aber wenn alles verschleiert ist, dann ist ja Default ja immer
zeigen. Also dann bist du ja nicht vorgewarnt.
Na doch, also das Bild wird ja so, also kennst du diesen Effekt?
Das ist einfach so ein großer gauscher Blurfilter.
Da wirst du schon noch erkennen, ob da was ist, was du sehen willst oder nicht.
Aber ist das nicht auch schon sehr invasiv? Ich meine, sowas willst du ja eigentlich
auch nicht haben, oder? Schwierig.
Ich habe lieber einen Graufilter, den ich dann eigenverantwortlich abschalten
kann, kommt eine Warnung, pass auf, hier fliegt der ein oder andere dick dann,
da kommt der Cyberflash, wenn du Pech hast, so ne, kann ja sein,
als dass ich ein Gesetz habe, das jede Kommunikationsplattform verpflichtet,
alle Bilder zu scannen mit einer AI.
Sorry, also da glaube ich, da haben wir nicht eine Lösung, sondern haben wir
einfach nur das nächste Problem.
Tja, ist aber in Kraft.
Danke ihr blöden Wichser.
Ja, hier wird auch dann noch im Artikel zu Recht das Problem des Overblocking.
Das meine ich doch mit, was ist mit ziviler, konsensueller Cyberflasherei.
Die sich mir übrigens eher erschließt, als der Urge.
Ich verstehe die Leute einfach nicht.
Das ist das Problem. Wir verstehen die Leute einfach nicht mehr.
Was heißt nicht mehr?
Das eine Mal, wo du irgendwie den falschen Pilz im Wald gegessen hast und für
einen kurzen Moment meintest, der Baum redet mit dir.
Und du hast die Menschen alle verstanden.
Das ist jetzt nicht mehr so. Das ist die große Ausnahme.
Wir wollten noch eine gute Nachricht machen.
Oh, noch eine gute Nachricht.
Ja, wir haben ja schon.
Gute Nachricht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt ein Artikel von Anna Biseli ist.
Hurra!
Ich wusste doch, wir haben einen von Anna.
Das war die gute Nachricht. Ein Artikel von Anna Biseli.
Wir haben schon vor einigen Wochen darüber berichtet, dass die Untersuchungen
bei Radio Dreieckland rechtswidrig waren.
Das ist das freie Radio aus Freiburg. die
über das Thema und das Ermittlungsverfahren und die polizeilichen und juristischen
Vorgänge um die Webseite links unten in die media.org berichtet haben und dabei
auf ein Archiv dieser Seite verlinkt haben.
Ein Archiv dieser Seite, ich werde nicht müde ist zu betonen,
dass auch irgendwie, ich glaube,
irgendeine Polizeibehörde mal verlinkt hatte oder so und das dazu geführt hatte,
dass dann dieser Radiosender, dieses freie Radio eine Hausdurchsuchung in seinen
Redaktionsräumen hatte, darüber haben wir schon gesprochen,
jetzt kommen wir,
zu dem Fall selber, links in die media.org so eine Open Posting Seite also wie
eigentlich alle in die Mediaseiten,
wo Menschen eben Berichte verfassen können und auf links unten ein Indymedia-Outlet quasi,
Indymedia steht für Independent Media,
wo gerne mal politische Gruppen Bekennerschreiben veröffentlicht haben.
Und neben vielen anderen Inhalten.
Was hat das Innenministerium gemacht?
Das Innenministerium hat gesagt, okay, es gibt einen Verein,
der diese Seite betreibt, eine Vereinigung.
Und diese Vereinigung verbieten wir jetzt. Das ist nämlich jetzt eine kriminelle Vereinigung.
Und deswegen darf es dann diese Seite nicht mehr geben, weil der Zweck dieser
Vereinigung ist, diese Seite zu unterhalten. und weil es die Vereinigung nicht
geben darf, muss diese Seite jetzt weg.
So haben sie diese Seite aus dem Internet geschafft und haben dann Hausdurchsuchungen
bei den Menschen gemacht, die unter dem Verdacht standen, administrativ diese Seite zu betreiben,
und damit jetzt nicht mehr nur eine Seite betrieben haben,
wo eventuell was an der Inhalte-Redigierung oder sowas beanstanden wurde oder
was an IP-Adressen gespeichert wurde,
sondern sie waren ja beschuldigt, Mitglieder einer kriminellen Vereinigung zu sein.
Und dann sind sie da eingeritten und haben gesagt, ja, hier ist ja eine kriminelle Vereinigung.
Und haben dann insgesamt knapp 200 Datenträger sichergestellt,
Laptops, Festplatten, SD-Karten.
Und haben dadurch keinerlei Erkenntnisse gewonnen.
Haben die Asservate aufbereitet und haben festgestellt, ist ihnen aufgefallen,
ist ihnen aufgefallen, haben die
gemerkt, dass der überwiegende Teil verschlüsselt war. Haben sie gemerkt.
Okay.
Hat das Wünnbergische Landeskriminalamt dann eben gesagt.
Der Tatverwurf ließ sich also nicht erhärten. Die Ermittlungsverfahren wurden
dann eingestellt und die Datenträger wurden zurückgegeben.
Und jetzt wurde eben gesagt, und diese Durchsuchung, die da überhaupt stattgefunden hat,
die war nicht verhältnismäßig, es gab keinen ausreichenden Anfangsverdacht und
die ganze Aktion war einfach ein komplett daneben und kompletter Overshoot.
Auch sehr schön, hat halt nur sehr viele Jahre gedauert.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie lange das her ist. Wir hatten da Betroffene auch auf dem Kongress.
Das war, also das ist ewig her. Das ist halt jetzt wirklich weit über fünf Jahre
später, dass das alles geklärt ist. Aber was ich sehr schön finde, ist am Ende Folgendes.
Jetzt zitiere ich ähnlich Anna Wieselli. Schon die Ermittlungen wegen angeblicher
Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung in Bezug auf die frühere Open-Posting-Seite
waren allesamt eingestellt worden.
Das Vereinsverbot besteht unterdessen weiter.
Warum? Jetzt Tim, Frage ist, warum besteht das Vereinsverbot weiter?
Ja, die haben gesagt, okay, Ermittlungsverfahren wegen Bildung einer Krönelvereinigung, alles Quatsch,
Hausdurchsuchung, Quatsch, alles Unsinn, aber das Verbot dieses Vereins,
das hat weiterhin Bestand. Warum?
Muss ja irgendjemand auch gegen klagen.
Genau, und das können nur Mitglieder.
Und bisher hat sich keins gemeldet.
Aber ich meine, wenn man jetzt nichts zu befürchten hat, dann könnten wir uns doch bekennen.
Ich glaube, also dieser Hund, den Hund würde ich jetzt echt gerne mal langsam
wieder schlafen legen. Aber geil, ne? Also du müsstest,
es haben mehrere dagegen geklagt, aber nur die betroffene Vereinigung selbst
ist befugt, ein Verbot anzufechten und bisher hat sich niemand zu einer Mitgliedschaft
in der kriminellen Vereinigung bekannt.
Wir könnten ja sagen, dass es uns betroffen gemacht hat.
Nee, du musst Mitglied sein. Du musst Mitglied der betroffenen Vereinigung sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die uns aufnehmen. Ich weiß auch nicht, wen wir fragen können.
Wo wir einen Mitgliedsantrag stellen können.
Dieser Fall, das ist von vorne bis hinten ein Skandal, dass es eigentlich darum
geht, eine Webseite runterzunehmen, dass man die Betreiber zu einer kriminellen Vereinigung erklärt,
Durchsuchungen dort macht, dass alles dann viele Jahre später als rechtswidrig
ist, sicher abgeurteilt wird. Aber das ist schon, es ist,
Eigentlich hätte ich halt viel lieber mal einen Bericht darüber so,
wer hat diese Entscheidung getroffen,
wer hat das in die Wege geleitet, wer hat die Sachen unterschrieben und würde
mich mal interessieren, was sind die personellen Konsequenzen für das,
wo diese Menschen jetzt über Jahre drunter gelitten haben und sie über Jahre
dadurch klagen mussten und was nicht alles.
Das interessiert am Ende keinen.
Das interessiert keinen mehr. Insofern doch keine gute Nachricht.
So ein Mist.
Tja.
Ja. Das war's. Das war's für heute.
Mehr gibt's nicht zu berichten. Also es gibt vielleicht noch mehr zu berichten,
aber mehr berichten wir nicht.
Es ist vielleicht abschließend,
Ich weiß, es ist schwierig, in diesen Zeiten nicht irgendwie allen möglichen
Scheiß in sich reinzufressen und zu verzweifeln.
Und irgendwo müssen alle diese negativen Emotionen ihren Ausgang finden, ihren Kanal finden.
Und das müssen sie auch tun, weil ihr dürft jetzt auch nicht alle in euch reinfressen.
Aber versucht doch mal, Wege zu finden, die andere sind, als irgendwie direkt
den Nächsten oder die Nächste neben euch irgendwie anzuschreien.
Und eure, diejenigen, die euch vielleicht noch von den Werten her am Nächsten sind, anzugreifen.
Und irgendwie euch darüber zu beschweren, dass es große, große völlig sinnlose
Kriege in der Welt gibt und in Konsequenz daraus große, kleine,
sinnlose Auseinandersetzungen in euren eigenen Communities zu führen und den,
Gegner nebenan zu suchen und euch auf eure Differenzen zu versteigern und in
Social Media gegenseitig anzuschreien und die ganze Zeit nur davon zu reden,
was andere falsch machen und anders machen müssten.
Weil es die Volksfront von Judäa.
Ich wollte sie jetzt nicht nennen, aber es ist natürlich die Volksfront von Judäa,
die die Ursünde begangen hat, sich von uns, der jüdischen Volksfront, abzuspalten,
Und damit unser Feind zu werden. Wir hatten einen gemeinsamen Gegner, das waren die Römer.
Aber die jüdische Volksfront ist der Feind. Oder was ist die Volksfront von Judäern?
Ich glaube, wir sind die anderen.
Achso, in dem Moment muss ich da...
Nur so eine Idee.
Denk mal drüber nach. Bis bald.
Wird das hier heimlich gefilmt?
Ciao, ciao.
Was heimlich ist es?